I'm a Thal animation director and
industrial light magic and I'm here to
talk to you about giant robots battling
giant monsters
you know the animation industry the
visual effects industry has changed a
lot in the last few decades in terms of
the business end of it certainly in
terms of the technology that we're using
you know when I started out we were if
we wanted to do creatures and movies you
did it with stop-motion animation
little puppets and now of course
everything's computer graphics but in
terms of the actual job of the animator
of creating performances from characters
believable performances that job really
hasn't changed a whole lot
job one is just creating characters that
an audience looks at it and believes it
whether it's a monster or a thinking
character or speaking character that
when they look into the eyes of that
creature they believe that it's thinking
and living and breathing when we're
doing a film with creatures the more
outlandish an alien they are the more we
need to look to nature to inspire us but
also to sort of ground the creatures in
things that are familiar at least in in
detail so we look at all different kinds
of animals and skins in the way they
fold and different scale patterns and
you know even extinct animals like
Dunkleosteus these awesome teeth and
mother nature is full of weird-looking
eyeball so you just go out and search it
it's awesome
people often ask you know when when you
know that something's finished and I
think as with anything creative it kind
of has to be taken away from us you've
got the artists you know the supervisors
and the artists on the project who are
trying to make the image imagery as cool
and as detailed and as interesting as
they can and then you have the producers
who you know as their job just sort of
at some point say enough you know we
have to fit our time and our budget into
this box and it looks great the client
is happy you know and step away from the
keyboard and stop working on it we
really need someone to tell us when
enough is enough because we just we
can't help ourselves